what is up everybody it's annamac here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down everything you
need to know about the former ninja and
current sound hashirov the demon slayer
core the one the only flamboyant
gigachad tengen uzui i will cover
tengan's backstory his epic powers and
his role in the wider demon slayer story
oh and yes i will talk about the fact
that this man has not won but three hot
ninja wives and once you've seen this
video through to the very end you too
will definitely also be able to find
three hot ninja wives just like tangent
uzui disclaimer this is not financial
advice or relationship advice anyway
let's get into it if you guys enjoy our
demonstrator content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're
looking for a completely free way to
directly support this channel don't
forget to subscribe hit the bell and
select that option that says all i know
that might seem like a little thing you
might think that one person subscribing
doesn't make a difference but it's
actually really important on youtube
please be advised that this video will
contain spoilers about tengen's origins
life story and unique powers and
abilities i will also talk about what
happens to him after the entertainment
district arc but if you'd prefer not to
know you just want to know his backstory
and powers but not how the arc ends i
will give you another spoiler warning at
that point in case you want to dip out
then you can't see the video through to
the end and find your three hot ninja
wives but it is what it is tengen uzui
comes from a shinobi or ninja family and
he was one of nine siblings his family
was extremely committed to the shinobi
profession and three of his siblings
died before they reached the age of 10
due to the extreme ninja training
methods that they were put through and
if that wasn't enough the remaining six
siblings including tengen were
essentially forced to fight each other
to the death by their own father because
all the siblings were made to wear masks
during this fight they didn't even know
whom they were fighting and so tengen
only realized what was really going on
after he had already killed two of his
own brothers in the end only tengen and
one other brother survived and while
tengan's last surviving brother accepted
their father's belief that shinobi must
be willing to commit even the harshest
acts in order to protect their clan
tengen simply could not accept this
horrible mindset so he decided to
abandon his clan and he left the shinobi
village of his birth along with his
three hot ninja wives owen speaking of
his wives the uzui family practiced
polygamy and so tengen was made to go
through an arranged marriage with three
kunoichi women who were chosen by the
head of their shinobi clan after they
left their clan tengen encouraged his
wives to completely re-evaluate their
most fundamental values from a very
young age all ninja are taught to place
their clan and their mission above all
other things including their own lives
if ashinobi must sacrifice his life in
order to complete a mission then so be
it however after abandoning his clan
tengan also abandoned those values he
always encouraged his wives to value
themselves and their own lives over any
mission and that proves that tengan
really cares about his wives and that he
values human life over codes of honor
and clan loyalties he even considered
exterminating his former clan in order
to prevent them from committing more
evil deeds but in the end he just
couldn't go through with killing his own
father and brother after leaving the
uzui clan tangent met kagaya ubiashiki
and he joined the demon slayer corps he
climbed the ranks of the organization
until he eventually became the sound
hashira we first met tengan when all the
hashira attended tanjiro's trial the
trial that he had been put through by
the demon sire core for protecting his
demon sister instead of killing her
right away which is what demon slayers
are supposed to do to demons like all
the other hashira tengen was skeptical
about the idea that a demon could be
good and could fight on the side of the
demon slayers but at the same time he
also seemed a bit intrigued by the whole
situation that said our knowledge of
tengenuzui is extremely limited until we
get to the entertainment district dark
tengen plays a major role in this arc
and this is where we truly learn more
about his character and his incredible
powers tangent is introduced in the arc
in a hilarious way when he comes to the
butterfly mansion and tries kidnapping
some of the girls who live there tanjiro
confronts him and tells him to leave the
girls alone but tengen says that he
needs some of the girls for an important
mission when he realizes that out of all
the girls there aoi is the only official
demonstrator core member he decides to
take her but tanjiro inosuke and zenitsu
volunteer to go instead and tengan
ultimately agrees tengen then explains
their mission they are going to the
flashiest place in all of japan a place
full of lust and avarice the
entertainment district also known as the
red light district a place long plagued
by demon activity our first impression
of tengen uzui is that he is flame
buoyant and cocky and that he likes to
order everyone around while claiming to
be a god compared to them clearly this
is not the most humble and modest man
but you can't help but love him anyway
as i said before tengen is an absolute
giga chad with three hot ninja wives and
all three of his wives had already
infiltrated the entertainment district
in order to gather intel about the
widespread demon activity but their
secret communications with tengen
suddenly stopped so now tanjiro inosuke
and zenitsu must pretend to be girls and
infiltrate the three entertainment
district establishments that are most
likely to harbor demons this provides
for some excellent comedic moments and
once the demon is finally revealed all
hell breaks loose and we get to witness
the full extent of tangan's powers since
he was born and raised as a shinobi and
since he underwent incredibly stringent
training since he was a child tengen is
obviously exceptionally strong fast has
unbelievable stamina and is extremely
skilled in martial arts and
swordsmanship due to his brutal ninja
training which involved deliberate
exposure to poison in various amounts
tengan has an unusually high resistance
to poison he is believed to be the
fastest runner among the hashira and he
is able to go toe-to-toe with an
upper-ranked demon moon who managed to
kill dozens of hashira in the past this
in itself is an incredible achievement
but as the sound hashira tangan has
additional abilities related to his
exceptionally sharp sense of hearing
tangent's exceptional hearing allows him
to hear for great distances and he can
even hear what's happening far beneath
the ground by pressing his ear to the
floor on top of that he is able to use
echolocation to determine the structure
of underground caverns and who is
currently residing within those caverns
but tengen's sense of hearing isn't just
useful for recon purposes it is also
extremely useful in battle he has
analyzed combat maneuvers to the point
where he can read them like sheet music
he converts the rhythm of the enemy
attack into sound so that every fight
that he participates in becomes like a
song to him by hearing the rhythm of the
fight he can anticipate his opponent's
next move and he can also determine the
best measures to counter-attack those
moves essentially he can hear the
repeated phrases made by his opponent he
can anticipate what his next steps will
be and so he can attack between the
beats and during the rests essentially
dancing with his opponents and of course
as the sound hashira tenganuzui uses
sound breathing which is a breathing
style that imitates the properties of
sound especially loud destructive sounds
such as explosions when fighting tengen
uses two large cleaver-shaped nichiren
swords as well as anti-demon explosives
and wisteria-laced kunai he also relies
on help from his three ninja wives
especially when it comes to using the
poison laced kunai tangen is the only
known breath of sound user and his sound
breathing has three known forms
including first form roar which involves
the user raising his swords above his
head and slamming them into the ground
along with his anti-demon bombs creating
explosions that sound like thunder
there's also fourth form constant
resounding slashes an attack that is
both offensive and defensive in nature
and involves the user spinning his
swords while simultaneously releasing
bombs at his target and finally we have
fifth form string performance which
involves the user spinning his swords on
a chain while releasing bombs at the
same time now of course sound breathing
has more forms but we haven't seen them
in the story in his prime tangen is one
of the strongest hashida in demon slayer
and i just love him as a character he
has such amazing quotes like when he
says the following to a demon who is
jealous of him i'm a flashy brilliant
sexy guy i've even got three wives i
mean how can you not love this guy he is
determined and relentless he is strong
and brave he is flashy and brilliant he
has hilarious comedic moments and he has
strong moral values that he was willing
to abandon his entire clan for tengen is
definitely one of my personal favorite
characters in the entire story and if
you're an anime only strap yourself in
because you are about to witness the
full extent of tang and uzui's greatness
now i will give you another spoiler
alert as i will now be talking about the
ending of the entertainment district arc
and what tengen does after the arc comes
to an end if you want to wait and see it
for yourself in the anime then now is
the time to click off the video and if
you're a manga reader then you already
know exactly why i'm giving this second
spoiler warning now tengen doesn't die
during the big upper moon 6 battle in
the entertainment district arc but he is
seriously injured he loses an eye and an
arm and after daki and yutaru are
defeated tangent and his wives decide to
retire from the demonstrator core in
order to live a normal life from now on
this is something that they had wanted
to do even before tengen was injured but
as his injury would severely limit the
ability for him to fight effectively as
a hashida the events of the
entertainment district arc only
solidified tangent's decision to retire
when iguro says that the demonstrator
core can't afford to lose yet another
hashida after rengoku tengan says that
it's alright because tanjiro and the new
generation will rise to take their place
but even though he formally steps down
from the position of hashira tangan
along with his wives continues to
support the demon slaying core and they
would go on to help train future hashira
tangan is also seen guarding the
ubuyashiki family along with shinjuru
rengoku during the infinity castle arc
and that is it everything you need to
know about the chat of chad's tanganuzui
the sound hashira and now that you know
all of this you will surely be able to
mimic the greatness of tengen and find
three hot ninja wives for yourself just
like he did i mean i haven't tried this
out for myself yet but i'm sure that it
would totally work again disclaimer this
is not financial or relationship advice
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more demonstrator content in
the future just leave a quick like it
only takes a second but it really helps
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to anime pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you really
do have to go through the trouble of
clicking the subscribe button then
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all i know it's kind of
annoying but unless you do that you're
still going to miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime outpour
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma and kyle salisbury these guys are
absolute mad lads and disciples of lord
twigo himself and i can't forget all of
our the one tyr patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including
ingrata algital pate heffa the
red-haired fox hinokamien water the
toasted chi corey mcgowan the spike
lonely the car dylan isidor spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummings and che whitley finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivania temple king matthew and
demetrius water if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patreon exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
oh and if you don't have a patreon
account becoming a youtube channel
member gives you the same perks as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you